all right cookie
yes cookie where'd you grow up where are
you from originally boyle heights
boyle heights east side of l.a right
mm-hmm and uh tell me about your
childhood you have both your parents
when you were young
yeah for the both addicts with your
parents for drug addicts
yeah as a matter of fact that was a drug
baby yeah
did they raise you or did you go to your
um
yeah like but i had a lot of babysitters
how would you describe your childhood
kind of ugly crazy
what kind of stuff went on why what kind
of stuff went on
uh i was molested by my brothers by i
have four older brothers and i was
molested by three of them by except the
oldest one because he was gay
you know but that's why the only reason
why i think what age did this start
um it happened every night from like um
seven to like i turned like 12.
um
[Music]
and how that's how that affect your
my relationships suck because of that
it's just stuck now
because i think that's what it is right
how far did you go in school
to the fifth grade fifth grade
and then what what happened after fifth
grade
i just stood home and i actually like
ran away and then went back home and
they ran away and i was trying to stay
away from home actually
you were kind of out in the streets you
were out in the streets and stuff
oh yeah oh yeah i felt safer on the
streets i lived under the bridge for
seven and a half years
right there on what was it uh uh
boiling and all that so sort of
olympic and sort of the bridge right
there it's certainly happening they call
it the jungle
and the drugs were by the picture for
you
the products what drugs were part of the
picture for you so this is i was born i
was telling you i was a drug baby
yeah but you but on your own you started
using oh yeah yeah yeah
what age 13 smoking crack
did you have kids do you have kids do
you have kids
oh yeah i have six kids and six
grandkids
and did you raise them no
no as a matter of fact a lot of during
their like i believe that i was in
prison
a lot of times most of the time what are
we in prison for
sales or possession uh um
mostly sales and possessions drugster
yeah
um and you're living where now i'm 30
main
elementary st george so you're in one of
the sros
i guess another project wilkie it's
called project working
no you're not on the street at least no
not anymore because it wouldn't be there
you so you lived on this in the tent or
whatever on the street oh yeah
yeah yeah a long time years
and what's your drink today okay same
thing
yeah how do you support yourself well
i'm a master i'm a hustler i'm period
you know i mean
yeah whatever comes my way i've done a
lot of pretty [ __ ]
believe it or not yeah besides working
the streets that's like nothing compared
to other stuff i've done
you know that's a rough way to make a
living no
oh yeah i was [ __ ] up yeah what's
what's the worst thing you've
experienced
um getting raped
getting raped out there by some tricks
yeah and getting my money taken away
back
and i was like you know
uh yeah i thought he was gonna stab me
they gotta have my compact right here
and [ __ ] just bounce back i was like
oh hello
and looking back at your life i mean do
you
do you make a connection between what
happened with your your parents and and
where you're at today
yeah it's it's like [ __ ] i'm doing
the same thing to my kids that did it to
me
saying [ __ ] thing yeah sucks
i was thinking about that the other day
too
as a matter of fact yesterday my
daughter calls me because she's you know
she's about 21 and she's so beautiful
too though but she's in idaho because
they're in idaho
and they're like a monkey homie you pay
for my refrigerator you're fundamental
and i'm like yeah
yeah so if i got to do that because i
never really done nothing for him
you know he says just be in prison or in
the streets
but i looked through my stepmom and
rehearsed my mother was a good parent
a good mother yeah
yeah do you do you think it was just the
role models that you had
that led you here or do you think it's
my choice
after a while my choice you take
responsibility for it oh [ __ ] yeah yeah
hi i'm a coroner
i don't have no i don't have an apology
um um admitting to my
faults whether it's a crime or not or
just whatever i do i've done in life you
know what i mean it was my choice i'm a
woman do you see a solution do you see a
way out
yeah it's real simple to stop using yeah
right oh that's
great yeah i mean problem solved well
yeah
and just you got to change everything
you know i mean i believe in that
but i don't know i don't
i don't have i like it tonight i like
getting higher
do you think you could stop if you
wanted to i have i have yeah
mm-hmm for about seven and a half years
yeah really yeah i was living
that was a baseball i worked at a power
plant union
250 an hour worked on the water i could
do it i've done it before
and you went back to using my son passed
away he had my son i woke up my son was
standing next to me he grabbed that
just [ __ ] me up [ __ ] me up and um
in the beginning it was like like um
because of that that i i wasn't using
but his dad started using again and
because i'm starting short
i came back to la8 because i don't want
to stay over there and i'm gonna start
using over here
so uh ever since then i've been using
does crack still have you know an effect
on you
the way it once did or you just addicted
and you have to have it i think it's
like more like i have to have it like
you want to wake up in the morning
i mean like right now when you stop me i
was gonna go by and take my hair i'm not
gonna let it
i really was i was like oh my god really
i need 50
whatever
do your friends do your friends do i
have friends
uh very few really feel like over here
you mean well anywhere
in life oh you know what my dad my dad's
my friend
more than anything right now um and i
have one girlfriend
and her name is flaka she's
but she don't come down here she lives
in the casinos whatever but yeah
she's just good at she said her and one
other girl named francis she doesn't
matter
she's waiting for me right now i'm done
like back in america
um what emotions do you deal with um
are you depressed or anxious or angry or
well i've been diagnosed
by the skills by the site
that i just said i'm bipolar
schizophrenic and psychotic disorder
that's like what the [ __ ] is all that
psychotic so that picks me out like
really
i guess
and the crack does what for you in terms
of your
in terms of your personality
[Music]
i think it just numbs me more than
anything
from your childhood memories and stuff
like that well i could deal with dog
with that off and on a lot of times
already and
you know um i'm alright with that i
already forgiven my brothers and i've
written them letters and told them why
would they do that to me why did it do
that yeah do they think i don't remember
they [ __ ] me up you know me and as a
matter of fact all my brothers are all
dead except one
and he's like one of the uh my brother
started the
the the be my lesson when i was little
girl he died first that was a trip
he got yeah he got shot 14 times times
11 i was like [ __ ] yeah i mean
everything has every dog has your day
you know um using a gang he wasn't a
gang from stone espresso
yeah but he got killed the day after he
got out of prison after doing 10 years
flat
if mama didn't get to see him it's too
bad for her you know
i didn't care i knew that he was you
know they're like the one that's alive
or not
um he'll deal on me because me and my
friend we all use drugs
all my other guys use heroin certainly
even my dad right now
as a matter of fact he's in a program
who's trying to stop it imagine
so the entire family's your entire
family my whole entire family yeah
and it's mostly heroin or crack heroin
and cocaine
yeah um yeah you played around with
other drugs too
i used to use heroin for a minute but
then i was like
i got too skinny i just i couldn't i
think i look ugly i can start my
my just my features are like just
changed like rapidly ugly like
nasty
so i stopped using that kicked out here
by myself and so yeah i was
talking about that i didn't have enough
with the rock you know yeah
did you have dreams as a kid of doing
something with your life i wanted to be
a i wanted to be a lawyer
a lawyer yeah as a little girl but yeah
so i was so struggle with that you know
but i have a learning disability too so
whatever so i just gave up on school
in the fifth grade yeah yeah
what's the most important lesson you've
learned in your life
dad no matter where i go that just
because these people are like
right now like you know you'll see the
homeless and people like on skin road
and
and like when i was even under that
bridge a good example i was living under
that bridge um
i met a lot of people i met a lot of
people there and elevated out a
few people that were like one time i met
this man he would have never had that
but he's like he was telling me his life
and he was a judge at one time
and he got added to cocaine and then he
went to rock and
i was like no way then and i was like
do you believe in my god well it's a
story that i'm telling right
so uh he took me one day to his uh
ex-wife's house and
it was a beautiful [ __ ] house dude it
was so bad
and and then he showed me the produce of
him when he wasn't i was like what the
[ __ ]
you didn't believe me i did but like i
did it i was like come on
i just yeah you know but yeah what a
trip
you never know who's who you know and my
dad always told me
i don't know how ugly and who it is you
always respect them and no matter what
you know
don't realize i was like what's your
favorite memory
in your life my favorite memory in life
duplexes and stuff and seven houses in
east and um and that was up from julian
drexel
and my it was right there when you sit
other because i had the biggest room
i had my own restroom in my room my home
daughter calling out the house and i was
doing
i'm the youngest and the only girl and i
yeah that's what i liked i liked that
house it was beautiful i was
kept up properly that was real i think i
was like about 11
around her 12.
it would spend the roughest time in your
life the roughest time in my life
[Music]
when i lived um before i even got to the
jungle to the
to the to the um under the bridge
i was staying in like um
like i first left my house right i was i
think about 12 13
and um and i was sleeping in the in the
alleys i was sleeping
eating out garbage cause that was like
the roughest time of my life but there i
would never get it
all right cookie well thank you so much
for sharing your story all right and i
wish you the best of luck
thank you thank you very much
you